on a commencé à stocker beaucoup de deux
livres en réserve l'entrepôt de cette
librairie de montréal déborde de livres
c'est que les libraires font des
réserves durant temps des fêtes on
stocke toujours beaucoup on stocke
encore plus cette année parce que on a
été prévenus que c'était fort possible
que plusieurs tout allait tomber
marquant plus vite que d'habitude pour
comprendre cette pénurie il faut
remonter avant la pandémie le livre
étant moins attrayant les papetières ont
ajusté leur production ils ont fermé les
moulins ont changé la vocation de
certains moulin pour faire du papier
d'emballage tout sans avoir par colis
des boîtes mais pendant le confinement
les gens se sont remises à lire le
nombre de livres vendus au québec a
grimpé de près de 30 % entre avril 2020
et 2021 le livre est devenu à la mode ce
qui fait qu'à me demanda à mater et que
l'offre a baissé en mai tempête parfaite
j'ai lu des rapports qui parle de
pénurie de livres aux états unis pour
les faillites d'états des deux villes
même si nos papetière roule à plein
régime la compétition entre imprimeurs
canadien et américain est féroce la
porte de papier et stab
mère sans voir d'autant présentement
les éditeurs québécois qui imprimait en
asie se sont aussi buté à l'explosion du
prix du transport par conteneurs
quand ça vient d'asie
ça passe par vancouver puis cet été on
avait aussi problème des feux de forêt
il ya des titres qui sont arrivés
beaucoup plus longtemps parce que les
trains pensait plus à cause des fous les
maisons d'édition font des pieds et des
mains pour s'ajuster à la demande qu'on
va prendre des décisions très en amont
avec des très gros tirage donc des gros
risques
en espérant ne pas se tromper des
dépenses supplémentaires qui feront
grimper le prix des livres on n'achète
plus cher on vend plus cher la facture à
votre fils tu m'aimes consommateurs en
40 ans d'expérience
j'ai jamais vécue je pense mon grand
père mon père non plus on jamais vxo une
situation inédite comme bien d'autres
durant cette pandémie ici et lise allard
radio canada montréal